[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got a leader here thank
you so much for doing this sir thank you
so much for having me it's been a while
uh we've been talking about this for
what feels like a
whole year um and we've got a lot to
we've got a lot to talk about
absolutely i think our original idea was
we were gonna like get together and
order pizza from like
every pizzeria in new york city and try
to do it in person but uh kovit had
other plans but uh here we are
um let's just start with your background
and kind of where you grew up and what
you did before you started slice
yeah of course um i come from three
generations of small business owners
predominantly in the pizza industry my
parents
lived in new york in the 70s my older
brother was born here
and they owned a pizza shop called
charlie's pizza on 75th and 3rd
and then they moved back to what was
then called yugoslavia
i was born i have a twin brother and
then in 1990
we decided to all move back again back
to new york
my uncle uh went back into into the
pizza business
today i've got about 30 family members
that own small business pizzerias
as far out as arizona and alaska
and i personally went down the tech path
i have a computer science and a math
degree and right out of school i
launched the tech support business
and we were one of the pioneers in the
whole on-site tech support
movement around brands like geek squad
and our brand was nerdforce and there
was another one called nerds on site
and i franchised the model so
decided to franchise the business um in
2005
uh this was about three years in and by
2008 we had 124 franchise locations
and i sold the company to a publicly
traded msp provider managed service
provider
um and i share all this all of this
background because
it'll actually be really relevant when i
go into the slice story and why it's
important
absolutely it sounds like you just
merged your two two parts of your past
for a slice so explain kind of what was
the impetus for the idea for slice
um and kind of how did you guys get
started yeah so uh operating nerdforce
one of the things we did was we were the
on-site tech support
department for small business for small
businesses who could not afford to have
a full-time
technology staff and um
as part of that mandate we would manage
websites for
some small businesses and so after
selling that company
a lot of friends and family members that
own pizza shops wanted me to help them
with websites
um and this was also around the time
when online ordering
was becoming really common especially
for the big brands like dominoes and
pizza hut and papa john's and so
um you know trying to figure out what
what should i do next uh i had just sold
a business
um i'm an entrepreneur at heart and so i
realized that there could be an
opportunity
to power the technology for
this one vertical i just didn't know how
how big the opportunity was
so study the industry and i was blown
away by a couple of things one
the the industry is just massive it's a
47 billion dollar industry this is the
pizza industry
in the u.s that doesn't include digiorno
it doesn't include you know pizza sold
at 7-11
that's revenue that passes through about
77 000
pizza restaurants in the us and so that
was like
holy [ __ ] massive can i can i say [ __ ]
of course now i can um number two
it was i was operating under the
assumption that dominoes
pizza papa john's little caesars
that they were the majority of this
category and what i learned was that
they were
the minority combined in fact 75
of all pizza locations in the us are
non-big chain locations they're small
businesses and so the way it's broken
down is
about 43 000 are independent out of the
77.
you have another 12 000 that are small
chains
that have similar needs and then you've
got about 20 to 22 000 locations that
are what i call big pizza
and so the moment i learned that was the
moment that i realized that we can
actually create
what i call a reverse franchise model
and what that is is
how do we unite local pizza empower them
with the same
value-add services that franchise
companies
realize but without the franchise
element without that downside
because you know entrepreneurs want
their their
creative freedom as i say and so uh the
idea was to launch the world's largest
pizza chain
composed of small business um and
entrepreneurs who are
in business for themselves not by
themselves
yeah and so one of the things obviously
is people see delivery
associated with anything you guys do and
immediately they compare you to
uh seamless grubhub you know name
doordash
name your kind of food delivery service
um i think that
you and i both look at the business very
very differently it's much more of kind
of a
shopify type um you know arming the
rebels with a suite of products and a
platform
talk through the difference between
those two models like just being food
delivery versus being more of like
shopify for small business
uh pizzerias and kind of why you chose
the latter
absolutely uh and look when i launched
the business uh
doordash and uh uber eats and and some
of these players that
didn't even exist um i launched the
business
in order to you know i don't like using
the word disrupt so
what's another word for disrupt but in
order to give
entrepreneurs another option to the
franchise model
you know if somebody wants to launch a
small business pizza shop
or really a pizzeria in general because
they're passionate about the craft
they have two options they can go and
buy a domino's location
invest over a million dollars and they
get
economies of scale they get a known
brand um
technology and all of these investments
that
the corporate office kind of provides
however they've got to completely give
up their creative freedom
it is not their location it's a domino's
location
and so thousands of entrepreneurs went
and launched 42 000 independent
pizzerias
literally reinventing the wheel from
step one
simply because they didn't want to give
up their creative freedom and they were
passionate about
about the craft and look as a result
you've got all these different varieties
of of pizza
chicago deep dish new york think crust
detroit style which is amazing if you
haven't tried it
now they are fundamentally at a
disadvantage
and so when i launched the business it
was about
helping these independents come together
and empowering them first with
technology and we'll get into why that's
important
two with a brand that champions their
authenticity
um in three economies of scale and so
how do we
come together to realize things like
buying power
leveraging data to make better decisions
and so on and so forth
now i think that's a much more important
model because
our goal isn't to simply utilize small
business
in order to serve the customer um in a
in a unilateral way like we're not just
about the consumer
we're about making sure that the small
business succeeds
realizes better economies and then we
can pass that back to the customer so
for me the comp was dominoes and how do
we
create a domino's version for local
and digitize these businesses so that we
can go from
you know zero orders online to seventy
percent of their orders online
and there's so many benefits that come
with that so so real quick before you go
into that let's talk about
domino's specifically because i don't
think people outside of uh maybe
technology and investing really
understand the domino's story and
um we'll talk about my uh my affinity or
non-affinity for dominoes in a little
bit but
uh in terms of uh kind of that
technology story i think starbucks kind
of is similar but but domino's is pizza
obviously
walk us through what did they do over
the last you know five seven
eight years that has led to this like
meteoric rise in their stock price and
just the
the interest and tech story that they
have domino's is incredible absolutely
um a lot of people associate
our brand um voice
as an anti-dominoes and i wouldn't say
we're so anti-dominoes i would say
i i look up to what they've done and i
think many many other
categories need to learn from that
starbucks as you mentioned is another
more recently chipotle is doing a great
job
and so what dominos has done is
realized that in a digital customer
and in fact now i have the data is worth
four times more than an offline customer
and an offline customer thinks someone
who's
calling in to place the order okay why
is that important and why is that value
there
an online customer is ordering on
average
um 30 more food each time they
order you now also have the customer
record so you can influence
their behavior i can push notify you
text message email
i don't have to have five people
answering the phone and i'll give you a
data point
we measured the phone channel for
hundreds of locations on our network and
what we learned was that 22 percent of
all
phone calls go unattended to
either because the line is busy or the
customer was put on hold
and and then they hung up or nobody
answered
and 75 of all phone calls
are orders so i mean that's a
huge chunk of revenue being left off the
table
for anyone who's a phone based business
so
once domino's learned these things they
decided that they're going to be
all about digital and they have gone
from in 2010 i believe they were about
five percent of their volume was digital
fast forward to today they're at 75
percent digital
and that's created some amazing
efficiencies in their model primarily
better pricing for the consumer so
because it's more efficient to now
operate a domino's location because of
the digital aspect
i can now afford to give the consumer
better pricing
so dominos hasn't raised their prices in
12
years um and that's just plain you know
economics
and we're playing in a category that is
very value-centric
yes you and i can debate the best pizza
in new york
but for most of the country household
income is about 48 000
a year pizza is their night out in
that's the way they feed their family
and
domino's is a very affordable option
compare that to small businesses who
have now flocked to the doordash and
ubereats and grubhubs of the world
in order to solve for this digital gap
well
they have 30 35 take rates what do small
businesses do
what are these platforms known for
higher prices
and so dominoes realize this as well so
this is the second leg of their growth
they realize that local businesses are
raising their prices
in order to make up for that digital
uh push and so domino's really started
to focus on quality
so they knew that they had value
lockdown and then for the last five
years
they made a massive first tour towards
quality and making the consumer
uh feel better about uh the end product
it's
the combination of that plus price and
really all led by digital
is uh is why dominos has outperformed
google in terms of the public markets in
the last 10 years
and so on this there's a whole bunch of
uh very intuitive things so if
everyone's calling and they're not
getting through and you give them an
online portal uh it increases your
throughput it increases kind of your
brand affinity all that makes sense
what is the part about like the tracker
right and being able to get information
almost passively because to me that
feels
uh almost like a nice to have but when i
talk to people about
dominoes and online ordering and all
this stuff they actually bring it up way
more than i would think
right the ability to see like where is
it in the process has it actually left
yet or has it not
and you're starting to see this in like
the actual food delivery apps now
so is that something that maybe is
counter-intuitive like
the level of information that is
available even after you've placed the
order is important
or is that just i'm talking to some
weird friends and actually doesn't
resonate as much no it's definitely
really important um
and look i i would say we're a little
bit behind in this area and we're
investing heavily to make sure that we
create the tracker version for local
and you'll see that from slice in the
early parts of 2021 so i'm excited by
that
i think the reason why that's super
important for dominoes and it has been a
massive unlock
is because we've learned that pizza as a
behavior nationwide
is a last-minute decision and it's the
safest
most consistent last-minute decision
that families make or individuals make
when they place an order and because
it's a last-minute decision
there's usually some chaos in the
background by chaos i mean
kids crying guests are waiting for the
food
it's a very event-based industry so
sporting events
the oscars i don't know the bachelorette
premiere and so the tracker has become
really really important because it gives
the consumer trust
about you know where the product is
because it's a last-minute decision
got it and so let's talk about slice in
terms of you saw
all of this playing out over the last uh
decade or so
what are the parts of the dominoes kind
of technol
technology story that you feel like
really align with what you guys are
doing for small businesses and then
maybe where are the differences in the
model they've pursued versus what you're
pursuing
yeah look i would say what really drove
the domino's flywheel
was um their ceo at the time
and this didn't feel like
a valuable initiative but their ceo was
the first one out of
all major brands to make the call and
say that the point of sale system
has to be consistent in every single
location
so domino's launch something they call
pulse pulse is their operating system
inside the stores and also connected
with their centralized call centers and
their operating team
and so the moment that they plugged in
the same
and consistent point of sale solution
across
all of their locations they can now
build on top of that
network-wide consumer-facing initiatives
so think domino's rewards
well it it's honored regardless of which
dominoes you shop in
right and it's rewarding you for
behavior
regardless of which location inside
domino's network that you that you buy
from
that's not you cannot deliver on a
promise like that
on that kind of value if all those
locations aren't on the same tech stack
and so for slice one of our big
initiatives is
plugging in a consistent tech stack
across all of our
partner restaurants in order to
provide the consumer with a consistent
experience regardless of which local
pizza shop
they buy from now the end product is
going to be authentic
and unique and different and we can
still debate
who's got the best pizza but i no longer
have to
have anxiety about what experience i'm
going to get if i'm
ordering from joe's or johns of bleecker
or or
any other pizzeria and so i would say
that's a that's a that's just a massive
investment but it's an important one the
areas where i think
we're obviously not going to invest in
is
trying to commoditize the product um you
know a lot of people ask well why is
why would slice be this reverse
franchise if you can't control the end
product
i think we should celebrate that i don't
want to control the end product that's
why entrepreneurs go in business um and
i want to make sure that we can
have those debates about who's got the
best pizza for a long time
it would be a pretty sad world if the
only pizza we ever had was domino's
with all due respect so you know a good
analogy for me is
airbnb in terms of what they've done
with the hospitality industry
they celebrate the unique aspect of all
of the hosts
but the experience is pretty consistent
um
so i would say that's a that's another
model that i look up to but
again the area we're not going to touch
is is the end product the food
got it talk to me about how it's going
so far so you've got this like grand
vision we're gonna create the largest
retail chain of pizzerias we're gonna do
it with local
small business pizzerias uh we're gonna
build this tech stack and kind of start
to standardize stuff and learn from each
other
uh and and really kind of shopify as
like armed the rebels you're basically
going to do this against
the chains how so far have you seen
adoption from the
local small business pizzerias and then
also in terms of transaction volumes or
any metrics that you can share
yeah so we work with 14 000 locations
nationwide
now these locations are on at a
different part in the journey
because we we think of this as a journey
that we have to guide them towards
in order to realize that full vision the
reality is that small businesses
have no reason to trust us from day one
so we've got a network of 14 000
locations
some are just listed on our marketplace
where they're getting older volume and
sort of that light version of technology
and then some are now graduating to
what we call direct or we're managing
all of their online presence
and then the last tier which i'm most
excited about is project by slice
i think you've seen some of these things
in on twitter this is where
we take on all of the responsibility of
the pizzeria's brand both physically
and digitally bring in
co-branded boxes realize the vision of
the entrepreneur in terms of their own
brand
plug in a point of sale solution and we
get this this location to really operate
within our principles and it accelerates
their performance both
online and then ultimately offline so
those are the three buckets uh we just
crossed a billion dollars in gmv
that's top line volume in uh in lifetime
volume
and that's that took us 10 years and in
2021 we'll do over a billion dollars
alone
and so our growth rate has really
accelerated
uh part of that has you know to do with
with covid
and just the acceleration and adoption
from the consumer side in terms of
ordering digitally
but a lot of it also has to do with just
our team's execution
they're doing a great job and uh and i'm
excited about that so
yeah we'll do over a billion dollars in
gmv in 2021
uh we'll probably end the year with
about 18 000 locations
and then about 500 of those locations
are going to be project by slice
locations where you're going to see the
slice brand
very prominently in the experience but
it's going to live side by side with the
with the
with the local brand and i'm assuming
that
uh you would never go start slice
locations
or is that in the cards as well no we
would never start slice locations where
we on the location outright and it's
like
sliced branded no but what we are doing
is helping entrepreneurs
launch their own business i
fundamentally believe that postcovid
we're going to see one of the greatest
renaissances in
in local business that we've ever seen
and
one of my partners in my business our
investor jeff richards
who's been on your on your show shares
this sentiment
and so what we really want to do is we
want to have a program that allows
anyone who wants to go into this
business with uh with an opportunity
to do that uh even if they don't have
access to capital
so we're going to be launching new
locations with new founders
and then we'll also launch new locations
from
existing operators who have always
aspired to launch
multiple shops so i'll give you an
example
one of our best partners is billy's
pizzeria in crown heights brooklyn
they would love to have a second
location we're gonna we're gonna help
them realize that vision and what does
that exactly entail in terms of
somebody who's already in business
they've got one location they say hey we
want to start a second
how do you help them we're going to come
in with a full program where
if they have no access to capital we'll
provide that
we're going to plug in a digital first
operating system where
we're giving them a point of sale
solution we're setting them up with a
website
e-commerce omni channel presence we're
partners with google food ordering
instagram shopping next door trip
advisor i can keep going
going down that list um we can help them
realize their vision for their brand if
they want to refresh it
buying power on pizza boxes and cups and
menus and all those things
and so all they really need to do is
bring their operation operating
experience
um and and and off we go
and we have so much confidence that
with that kind of a collaboration that
the pizzeria is going to be set up for
success from day one
and we've got all the data to be able to
to be selective about
where the location can be and how to
drive consumer adoption to to these
small businesses
are these uh locations where there's
walk-in traffic as well as online
or are these almost like pseudo ghost
kitchens but just like pseudo pizza
kitchens
yeah these are definitely retail store
fronts i personally do not believe in
ghost kitchens
espec at least as it pertains to the
pizza industry
okay explain why so i'll get to that in
one second
um we're talking about small footprint
pick up and delivery first digital first
pizzerias
uh we're not talking about restaurants
with big dining rooms so i don't believe
in that either
especially for this category and so the
reason why i don't believe in ghost
kitchens for this space is because
there is already enough kitchens in fact
every single month we see about um
100 to 200 locations just going out of
business on slice
and these are already built kitchens
that somebody
can access there's also again
42 000 independent kitchens
pizzeria kitchens in the u.s i wouldn't
say kitchen capacity
is the issue or and i wouldn't say that
a pizzeria is not accessible to the
consumer there's actually a pizzeria and
basically every neighborhood in the
country and so going and investing
in kitchens is
i think just the wrong approach um
going to why i don't believe in ghost
kitchens in general i think that's
a proposition that's been
really communicated well by third party
delivery aggregators
in order to justify 30 take rates so
here's the argument oh your your
business can't sustain the 30
take rate cool how about you open a
ghost kitchen
so that you don't have to spend as much
on real estate and therefore you can
afford 30
take rate where the third party is not
giving anything and the
local entrepreneur is giving up
everything in fact they're just
in essence at that point buying a job
and so i believe
that the value that's being left off the
table
from a real estate store a real estate
storefront where
hyper locally the consumer is going to
be aware of your brand
they can walk in pickup is a big deal
like just because delivery's available
doesn't mean every consumer wants
delivery
a lot of consumers prefer pickup
and and sort of that the brand equity
that can be built
with a retail storefront it's just
that value is much greater than going
into a ghost kitchen
now again it may make sense for
some big restaurant brand that just
wants to be pick up and delivery first
and wants to test out
a new territory by all means but
if you're in the pizzeria business and
you're going into the ghost kitchen
um you know sort of side of of the
industry
i believe you're leaving way too much
value on the table and you're
selling yourself short got it and so
obviously a lot of these operators um of
small businesses
both uh industry agnostic and in the
pizzeria space
uh have really struggled this year right
we've got kind of a public health crisis
uh we've got an economic crisis we've
got governments who
can't seem to make up their mind in
terms of you can open you can do outdoor
dining you can do indoor dining now you
can't do indoor dining
uh literally i couldn't tell you what
majority of major cities what the rules
are right now because it's just been
changed so many times
are entrepreneurs surviving right let's
just start there with just survival so
not thriving
not you know going to make enough money
this year to go on vacation
just literally how are they preventing
the fact that they
could possibly shut down man
it's uh well look most most are not um
when i look at outside of the pizza
space even within our network
we've got a bunch of partners who aren't
your traditional pizzeria
they're more of a restaurant i mean it's
it's impossible
it's impossible to survive um what i'm
seeing is
these locations being super creative
look i'll summarize it as just pure grit
this is just people who refuse to to
give up
um and they're inviting family members
to show up and work
because you know staff doesn't want to
show up and risk their
their health to come in and answer the
phone um
i've seen pizzerias start selling pizza
making kits
just to just to make you know some
additional capital
um you know i've seen them set up
obviously
outdoor spots for for sit down
but it's bleak it's bleak because
the suddenness of decisions that are
being made
by you know government
and city officials is
really really short-sighted and lacks
empathy and i think it lacks you know
knowledge of what it takes to even
launch or restart a business i would i
would argue
we did more damage by in new york
by allowing restaurants to open for
indoor dining partially
only to close them as of today
then just letting them not open
at all until things were in the clear
why
because the investment of bringing
things back and being
able to open partially is
massive it's it's no different than
opening fully
and so to do that and then only go back
and say okay now you have to close well
what happens to
and by the way not even giving
you know some some leeway not even
giving a warning just kind of like
five days before saying okay you're
closed
well what happens to all the inventory
that they bought what about all the
staff
that they hired with the promise that
things are only going to get better
what about rent and it's just it's wild
um you know in some cases again with
with slice we feel a little bit
fortunate because
takeout and delivery first pizza
restaurants have done
pretty well and they've put themselves
at risk but
they have uh succeeded in a lot of ways
but i mean i would say that's the
minority in the in the space
it's just it's wild and in new york city
it feels like
um pizzerias for the most part there's
some exceptions but for the most part
uh didn't really participate in what
i'll call like outdoor dining only right
many of these places are kind of walk-in
pickup
uh or delivery and so was that a
positive or a negative
aspect because many restaurants they
felt hey at least we can get some
revenue in the door we can serve people
outside especially when it's a little
bit warmer
since pizzerias didn't have that was it
maybe the business was unchanged because
they were doing
you know okay with the delivery and
pickup or how did that kind of play out
yeah i would say the demand and pick up
and delivery
definitely outweighed the loss in just
random walk-in traffic
um and and a lot of that was really
subsidized by by pickup and curbside
pickup
so what we saw was a massive lift
in pickup volume in a really cool way we
also
saw a huge bump up in
tipping for pickup orders which
traditionally doesn't happen
in fact there was a point moment in time
where
tips for pickup orders were greater than
delivery orders which was fascinating
um and then also much higher aovs
so by aov i mean average or val volume
i'm i have to remember i'm not speaking
internally
um and so as consumers shifted to
digital
they ordered a lot more food and then
they also
ordered a lot more for pickup in
curbside um and it was interesting a lot
of consumers chose pickup
in in some ways as an excuse to just
leave the house for five minutes
um i'm just you know speaking the truth
here
so of course so they've done they've
done fairly well
as long as they were smaller footprint
were they were a pickup and delivery
restaurant before kovid
um and i would say those locations post
kobe has done
have done very well the restaurants have
not
and so as you kind of think through this
is this a situation where you had a lot
of small business owners who were saying
hey look i'm not having people walk in
uh i know that i can get orders online i
know i can get delivery and they kind of
are
sitting around saying i need to improve
at this and so slice becomes a great
option it's kind of like people sitting
at home
and all of a sudden you know restoring
homes and improving homes
uh exploded because everyone's just
looking around saying like oh i need to
fix that door i need to you know paint
that wall uh it
feels like maybe in this situation
restaurants had to go from
digital kind of being a secondary
thought to like digital as the default
and that probably served as a tailwind
for you guys
exactly absolutely this is the first
time ever
in the last 10 years that i've operated
this business where
the number one priority for most small
businesses is digital
and then secondary is the telephone it's
usually it's been the other way around
now the phone still drives the majority
of of the volume in the space
across all categories not just pizza but
the adoption and the sense of urgency
around digital
has never been greater and you can see
this also with companies like chow now
my good friend chris who's the he's the
ceo there
they do more of a you know online
ordering tools for all restaurants
and they've seen a very similar um
breakout in terms of
adoption from restaurants so it's not
limited to pizza
this is across the board the sense of
urgency for digital
is is massive now i will say
for some restaurants unfortunately it's
it's a false promise
because digital isn't going to subsidize
ten thousand dollars in rent if you have
a big footprint
if you've got a big dining room uh or if
your restaurant was in like
corporate heavy locations let's call it
midtown manhattan
well it's a ghost town because most of
the volume they are doing during the
week
is people who live outside of outside of
manhattan that are commuting in
so anyway um digital has been
has been a huge unlock for for
restaurants
all right i asked a bunch of people for
questions for you and uh they did not
disappoint so i'm gonna rattle some of
these off and you just fire back with uh
with what you got
uh what is the biggest order that you
guys have ever seen on slice
oh man um i think there was one that was
like
twelve thousand dollars uh it was it was
i would have to go back and check but
i'm pretty sure it was in that vicinity
it was a twelve thousand dollar order
um and it was just like hundreds of pies
um and what's cool about that is we
still only charge two dollars for it
uh which is which is our our revenue
model and so for twelve thousand dollars
that one pizza shop received in business
um they paid us two bucks
um but i would say that was i think the
largest order why a flat
uh kind of per order fee
i think that that our revenue model that
our our fee model
is the most merchant friendly
while also putting the the
responsibility of success on slice as
well by that i mean
it's a win-win model it's a per order
fee
and what that does is incentivizes us to
continue to drive more volume
and it's a flat fee because it passes
the upside of digital to the merchant
and so because we know that online
orders go from
you know from a telephone of 20 orders
to an online order that is on slicer
our orders are about 34 dollars on
average
you're passing that big upside to the to
the merchant
now if it was a if it was a
percentage-based um
fee then with higher order values we're
also getting more revenue
but i i wanted to cap it so that they
can
realize that digital is their most
valuable channel and
slices and attacks on that yeah that
makes a lot of sense
who's the most frequent user
um i hope it's one of our board members
um
now i would say aside from jeff richards
who
places orders for his family he's got
four kids um
the most frequent you know board member
uh in terms of users
i think the last time i checked is
there's a person in boston
who has ordered a large pie and
chicken fingers every single day for the
last four years
i mean every day i'm not even making
that up
um to the point where someone internally
was just like
can we send can we send a paramedic just
to like make sure they're okay
but literally every day a large pie and
chicken fingers
bored four years that is incredible have
you talked to
them have you sent them a thank you
anything
we definitely send out thank yous i
haven't personally spoken to them
i'll be honest like part of me is just
like i don't want to cross that privacy
issue but
uh or or line but yeah you've got
look we're in a business where it's a
highly repetitive highly frequent
category
i mean 94 of americans have pizza once a
month
and it's usually uh a habit it's usually
like once a week
and so you see that in the uh
in the usage um but yeah i love it
uh probably the most popular question
you get is
where's the best pizza uh don't pick one
give us a couple of uh
of your favorites um so i know this
from operating ten years what i know is
that the best pizza is the
one closest to you it's very simple
it's the one closest to you because
it doesn't matter who's got the best who
doesn't the reality is we call that your
home slice
the one that you grew up with the one
that's like in the corner of your street
that's that's the best pizza i can't
tell you which one that is you you know
that
you know that yourself which one is your
favorite
uh my favorite is pizzeria giove which
is right right behind me here on staten
island
it's incredible fitting crust it's one
of the best pizzas you'll you'll ever
have
um i also love lili's tavern which is
nearby
it's an institution on staten island
it's like a bar pie
so there's there's some really good
really good pizza on staten island
are you throwing pineapples on there
you know not not for me okay thank you
thank you there's a whole debate about
you know pineapple is it
does it belong on a pizza and the beauty
of of
of the pizza debate is that it works for
somebody
and that's special right that's awesome
it's the one place where you can have it
you know however you like it and so if
you like pineapples on your pizza
by all means but you know don't expect
me to try it
i'm there with you all refrain i thought
this question was really thoughtful uh
who's your customer so you've got
obviously people who are ordering
and kind of using uh the slice
technology but you also have the
pizzerias and so
how do you guys think about who the
customer is the consumers are customer
uh but we are merchant centric and i
know that sounds
very schizophrenic but it's uh it's real
our job and our mandate is to empower
small business pizza shops
to serve consumers in a way that is
rewarding easy accessible um
and and that's the only way we're gonna
keep local thriving and that's our
mission
if we don't make the consumer experience
better
and more rewarding then they're not
gonna buy from local places
um and so unless it has to do with the
consumer experience
slice will probably not necessarily get
involved
in terms of solving a pain point for for
the pizzeria
now fortunately most pain points
actually are reflected in the consumer
experience even if like a pizza shop is
paying
too much for flour well that's being
reflected in the price of the pie
and so we want to reduce the cost of
flour
but like whether the chef is wearing a
blue apron or a red
apron like that doesn't impact consumer
experience
and that that's those are not problems
we think about but we're a consumer
we're a consumer business got it
how important is the water
um you know depends on who you ask but i
would say
the water is much less important uh i
would say the craft
is really important and if you study the
pizza industry
and and just the history of it you had
immigrants moving predominantly to the
northeast mostly in the new york area
migrating from places like italy and you
know europe in general
and this is where that craft originally
landed from from europe
and and so as a result
regionally i would say the northeast has
the best pizza but
you have great pizza in connecticut you
have great pizza in
vermont you have great pizza in new
jersey so it's clearly not the new york
water
and now you're starting to see some
great pizza in like new york transplant
locations like south florida
phoenix arizona uh a little bit now in
la but really the reason why
you know a lot of places around the
country you don't find
the great pizza that exists in new york
is simply
that the craft hasn't really
transplanted to those locations
we want to do something about that um
my vision is to launch slice university
and
to really use and leverage technology in
digital
to help entrepreneurs learn how to make
better pizza
no matter where they are in the country
so are you albanian yugoslavian
how do you uh think of yourself and now
i basically ask you how do they think of
themselves because i realize that
sometimes the truth and what they
identify with is completely different
but
uh which one do you which direction do
you go
uh you're welcome to the balkans um so
i'm albanian
so my name is is probably the most
albanian name
um you know anyone will ever read it's
like
if your name is veto like you're italian
there's no question so that's that's
kind of what my name you know is like in
albanian but i was born in
what was then called yugoslavia um so
ethnic albanian from yugoslavia
and then since i was born yugoslavia
broke up into a number of different
countries and
macedonia was the southernmost call it
state
and so my family was from macedonia but
it's literally on the border of
macedonia and albania
okay so you threw me off earlier when
you said yugoslavia but everyone online
was saying that
uh you are obviously albanian look at
your name so that makes sense exactly
uh one of the questions was what's the
most albanian thing about you so you
can't use your name but what is the next
most albanian thing about you
it's my name um
and the fact that i'm in the pizza
industry i think
it's a really maybe for some people it's
a known fact but
albanians are incredibly well
represented
in the pizza industry and so
aside from my name the fact that i'm in
the pizza industry it makes me
incredibly albany
and so i want to finish up where we
started which is you said
30 family members are in the small
business pizzeria
kind of industry what do they think
about
slice and what you're doing is this like
a family affair
is this something where they get to test
some of the features first
like it just seems very unique that uh
there's a founder going after a market
that you're uniquely positioned to go
after
and it's not like oh you just were in
the pizza business or your father was in
the pizza business
literally your entire family it seems
like it's kind of talk through a little
bit about like building
a technology company in a space that has
such a material impact on
uh your extended family and and kind of
the lineage that you come from
yeah look it's it's all of the above i
would say uh it's a blessing and a curse
um it's a blessing for all the reasons
you just mentioned
um industry knowledge the ability to
work really closely with these operators
because they're family they're brutally
honest um so i'll give you an example
our pricing model
was the result of conversations with
family members that operate pizzerias
because we tried
you know a percentage-based model we
tried a flat fee per month
and neither really worked well and then
finally one of them was like look
what about just flat fee for order make
it super simple
and for a long time it was just two
dollars per order
so some amazing advantages
because of the relationships that
that i have with family members at on
p3s
i would say also difficult so when
something breaks or when something goes
wrong
they also don't hold back um they'll
show up to my office when when our
office was open
randomly they'll come into the office
and you know it's time to spend
you know now you've got to spend some
time with them um
they'll be the first to you know to be
critical they'll be the first to
celebrate the successes
um and i would say that the the last
thing the most important one is
um just being surrounded by these
operators who have gone through so many
different struggles
in the world of kovid has given a lot of
inspiration to
myself and everyone at slice and these
stories that we share on a daily basis
it was an inspiration for pizza versus
pandemic which is
a massive initiative that we launched in
partnership with slice out hunger
where we raised over 600 000
to feed frontline workers with with
free pizza but then that was in the form
of
fully priced orders placed for small
businesses
small business pizzerias in the dead
middle of pandemic
so just really inspired
is and then that passion and that
mission first culture that we have at
slice
is derived from from these uh from these
operators
ultimately family members yeah and then
before we get into
the rapid fire to finish up uh what's
your favorite memory of slice like
what's the moment where
uh there something happened and you were
just like this is why
uh i want to build this company anything
that sticks out in your mind there
yeah look i um we can stay here all
night with stories of bootstrapping
so i've operated the business both in a
bootstrap way
and then hyper growth vc funded
for the first six years i bootstrapped
the company
with a very small team zero pennies
raised
in 2015 we did 40 million in sales
4 million in net revenue and 3 million
in profit
and i was running the business from
different pizza shops or starbucks
nearby
no office no overhead uh we had one
engineer
and i would say one of the most
um just memory one of the most important
memories that i have
is uh february of 2015
i was kind of going through my excel
sheet i didn't have an accounting system
it was excel
i didn't even have quickbooks so we're
we're running 40 million in gmv through
through like excel and um i realized
that for the month of february 2015
we had done about 2 million in gmv
a little bit more and about 200
000 in revenue and 175 000 of that was
profit
and i'm just like sitting there at a
starbucks
and that was the first time that i ever
felt like
okay this this is going to work and that
was five years in
literally five years in um i had a
chance
and an opportunity to sell the company
so i got an offer for 18 million dollars
which i turned down um because i felt
like
if i treated my bootstrap company as a
new venture
that we could make it something much
more special and that's when i exited
bootstrap mode
raised my first round which was only a
million dollars in late 2015
um and it was off to the races since
then but
that's the moment the million was from
um founders of seamless web seamless
ultimately jason finger paul applebaum
they they were incredible wiley cerrelli
who founded
um single platform and sold to constant
contact
um ben's son from primary ventures
he's still on my board one of my closest
partners by the way if you're a new york
based company
startup and you're looking to raise
money reach out to ben
um you won't you won't regret it if
you're early stage
and then um a phone called contour
ventures
also new york based so that was a
million dollars
it was my way of getting them um
connected to the business because
the last thing i needed at that moment
was money like money was just like
flowing in
uh it was more about networking and
helping me build out the team
got it i asked the same few questions
everyone before i let them go and
you'll get to ask me one to finish up
the first is what's the most important
book that you've ever read
uh there's a book called elements of
style it's like
tiny tiny book um and it's a very
mechanical sort of utility utility based
book but it ultimately
what it does is it teaches you the right
aesthetics of writing
and communicating it was my
english professor in college showed up
to class when everybody else was giving
us textbooks like this thick
he came in with this paper thin book and
it changed uh it changed the way um
i communicated that's a great elements
of style
aliens believer or non-believer believer
why oh it's math
it's math i mean when you look up in the
sky and there's
millions of galaxies with millions of
solar billions of solar systems and
the likelihood that the same conditions
don't exist that they exist around
planet earth
i mean that's just impossible so yeah
it's just
it's yes it's not even a question
maybe i'm crazy but that's statistics
tell me
yes i uh i'm a believer as well so i
i don't think you're crazy you could ask
me one question to finish up what uh
what do you got for me
i mean the big question is what's up
with domino's come on you're like
i knew it was coming all right yeah i
don't even like dominoes that much
that's the crazy part here's the
craziest part of this whole thing so i
will finally admit this because
everyone's going to listen to it uh i
used to order dominoes not because of
the pizza because they had the cheesy
bread cheesy bread was really good and
you knew what you're gonna get super
unhealthy
right it's like basically you're like
giving yourself a heart attack by eating
it
uh and so i ordered it one time i
tweeted it ordered it a second time
tweeted it
and then i didn't do it the next weekend
and somebody tweeted at me it was like
dude where's the dominoes
and so i say oh i've got to get
dominance i did a third time a fourth
time and then after like four or five
times
it just became this thing and i almost
felt guilty
like not doing it because everyone was
like waiting for the dominoes uh
picture and so uh obviously i live in
new york city there's a way better pizza
than dominoes
i still think domino's is underrated for
what people think it is
right like having like a like a chain
you think that it's just cardboard
whatever like it is actually pretty good
pizza for
a chain but when you've got you know
joe's or bleecker street and like all
these
uh kind of world famous pizzerias uh
it's pretty hard to uh compare those to
dominoes
so i've uh i i've been thinking like
maybe i should just
wean myself off the uh requirement for
dominoes and instead just say hey look
every saturday we'll get pizza
uh but there's saturdays dude there was
people for
a long time who thought like i was just
loaded up on like domino's stock or
something
and they kept asking me like how much
domino's stocked you own i don't own any
domino's stock
uh but uh at some point i was just like
yeah this is getting uh getting out of
hand here maybe i should uh
ordering other stuff i will say on
twitter
i don't know if it's domino's related
but um i will say that
if anyone tweets about pizza bitcoin
or politics just expects a massive
audience
and so you combine two out of those
three
and and that's what you get yeah or do
you guys accept bitcoin that's the other
thing people wanted me to ask you
no we uh we actually just had a
hackathon and one of our engineers
um built the capability and so we'll be
able to
accept bitcoin for pizza i mean come on
bitcoin was invented for pizza so
we'll be able to do that i think we're
going to launch that at some point in
20-21
um i don't i forget what they use to
like
um do it you know integrate it but yeah
you'll be able to use bitcoin for pizza
i'll gladly accept it
uh whoever the engineer is you should
give them a raise they're so they're
obviously the genius of the group
in bitcoin you know in in 2014 i want to
stay
um i bought a butterfly labs machine in
my bootstrap
office and you know at home and
um we we mined seven bitcoin
wow this was way back in 2013 2014 i
think it was
i think it was around 100 80 or
something like that
yeah hey so
yeah all right hopefully you held on to
it yeah i love it
all right listen later thank you so much
for doing this obviously i'm a huge fan
of what you guys are doing anyone who's
helping small businesses
uh you know just kudos to you they need
all the help they can get right now you
guys have built a an amazing business so
highly suggest people go check out slice
download the app
uh where do you want to send them to
find out more about slice or
find you on the internet yeah just
download the slice app just go
go on the app store and search slice um
we're there online at slicelife.com
and for me it's elira sella
i-l-i-r-s-e-l-a
on both twitter instagram uh linkedin
and we're hiring we're hiring a bunch
so awesome all right man thank you so
much dude again in the future
thank you thank you so much for having
me